new demonstrations are breaking out in
Germany over the death of a 22 year old
in the city of Curtin he was reportedly
killed in a fight on Saturday with to
migrants now in custody two Afghans were
provisionally detained on suspicion of
homicide the reasons for and concrete
circumstances of the incident are not
yet known the German media reported the
incident took place on a playground
where three Afghan men started an
argument with a pregnant woman two
locals are believed to have stepped in
but that led to a fight breaking out
police say one of the men who intervened
later died from his injuries
well it comes on the back of violent
protests in another eastern city in
Germany which broke out over the
stabbing of a man in chim nets by people
described as being of Iraqi and Syrian
origin by police
[Applause]
[Music]
well thority czar blaming the rise of
the far-right for the current situation
in chimneys when today someone gives
Nazi salutes in our streets that's a
disgrace for our country we must get out
from our couches and speak up Chemnitz
government is at the forefront of the
movement making it clear that right-wing
radicalism has no place in this country
and that sentiment was echoed by
Chancellor Angela Merkel but it hasn't
stopped the anti-migrant alternative for
Germany party from making their way off
the political ladder in the country
these numbers on screen are from the
latest poll since violence broke out in
Chemnitz
you